JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
chef, Parti libéral du Canada
- Et on a réussi à sortir
des dizaines de milliers,
des centaines de milliers
d'aînés de la pauvreté
au fil des dernières années.
On a diminué, depuis 2015,
le taux de pauvreté
chez les aînés de 20 %.
- Est-ce que la pauvreté a
autant baissé chez les personnes
âgées de 65 ans et plus?
Oui, c'est vrai, mais il y a
des nuances à apporter.
Quand Justin Trudeau est arrivé
au pouvoir en 2015, le taux
de pauvreté des aînés
était de 7 % au pays.
S'il était resté à ce niveau-là,
plus de 460 000 personnes âgées
se seraient retrouvées
en situation de faible revenu
en 2019. Mais le taux a baissé
à 5,4 %. Il y en a donc
112 000 de moins.
Ça représente une baisse
qui dépasse un peu les 20 %
évoqués par Justin Trudeau,
mais on ne peut pas dire que des
centaines de milliers d'aînés
sont sortis de la pauvreté.
Vous vous demandez sûrement
comment on calcule le seuil
de faible revenu.
Selon Statistique Canada,
c'est quand une personne
consacre une part de ses revenus
20 % supérieure à la moyenne
des gens pour ses besoins
de base, comme se nourrir
et se loger.
Maintenant, pourquoi la pauvreté
a-t-elle baissé chez les aînés?
La bonification du supplément
de revenu garanti a possiblement
joué un rôle. Cette prestation-
là, qui est versée aux aînés
les plus pauvres, a augmenté
davantage que le coût de la vie.
Mais il faut ajouter que des
gens prennent leur retraite
en masse depuis quelques années
et qu'ils sont mieux nantis
qu'auparavant. Ils contribuent
donc à faire baisser
le taux de pauvreté.
Parmi les pays du G7, le Canada
arrive troisième, derrière
la France et l'Allemagne, pour
ce qui est du taux de pauvreté
le plus faible chez les aînés.
Mais c'est au Canada que
l'intensité de la pauvreté est
la moins forte. Ça veut dire
qu'il y a moins de personnes
âgées dans des situations
d'extrême pauvreté
comparativement aux autres